[Music]
in today's aid on your side with gas
prices climbing due to russian invasion
in ukraine and this expected for the
next few months we could all use some
sound advice on how to save on those
soaring prices some gas hacks now for
you from a consumer savings
gas prices fluctuate daily but you can
track the cheapest ones in your area by
using certain apps check out gas buddy
you just type in the zip code or you can
let them use your location to identify
the cheapest gas
per gallon in your area savings expert
andrea warwick encourages those of you
with memberships to costco to fuel up
there for some of the lowest prices go
early in the morning or late at night to
avoid the long lines you can earn free
gas gift cards by taking online surveys
go online to a site like swagbucks.com
or surveyjunkie you can earn points for
taking online surveys watching videos
running online web searches and even
testing new products and services all
those points can then be redeemed for
gift cards to gas stations the best way
to cut gas spending is to drive less
which you can accomplish by setting up a
carpool tour from work or school or even
the sports practice with other parents
you can even find ride shares using
sites like zim ride ride joy or
e-rideshare.com
be strategic buy your groceries from
stores that offer a gas savings program
where you can redeem rewards for money
off at the pump